Oh everybody I'm Laura I'm a front-end
developer Swedbank but today I want to
talk about music how we can code music
and I already notice that people get
really confused with this term and
despite that we know what this music we
know what this program but when it's
combined we become unsure what we are
talking about so to put it simple I'm
gonna talk about coding whereas an app
we can generate sound and which one we
can create music it's pretty simple as
this and the natural question might pop
up into your head so does this stop for
musicians or for programmers or we need
to have both kind of skill set to start
doing something with a programming and
the four answer to that I'm always very
keen to know about the audience how many
musicians do we have here who are
playing with some sort of the
instruments singing or creating music
perfect is a question how many
programmers do we have here a lot was
perfect to help any of these colleges
this is an advantage for sure but
honestly to start doing some of the
music program you do not need any of
that and I would say that can be as a
perfect entry point to start doing
something with either musical or
programming sites let's dive into 1843
1843 this is the German music
programming as an idea was already
introduced and as you see we did not
have the computers as we understand them
today but despite that despite that a
table she described in her words that
computing engine can be as a perfect
tool to create precise and scientific
music that means this topic is known for
a while and no surprises that nowadays
we have different ways how we can create
music with the code and today I want to
talk about two different programming
languages so that the first one our
universal programming language
JavaScript how many of you know
JavaScript of course almost everyone I'm
gonna show you two ways how we can use
JavaScript how we can do life
cohdon how we can create music and
change that on the fly and how can we
use that for our web applications how we
can create music there and then we will
talk about totally different programming
language with language which was special
great for music programming it is sonic
PI and I'm gonna show you as well how
can we do live coding and what would be
the differences let's start to
JavaScript and for that we need to meet
jeepers jeepers is browser-based
environment which enables us to create
audio visual art and today I'm going to
focus only on audio part nothing to do
notice needed a simple go to jeepers dot
C C and I'm gonna show you that here is
jeepers
on your left you can find tutorials
demos and useful information and full
right is for coding let's start with
something simple let's start with hello
world application right but as you
imagine we will not see hello world as
we get used to that a music programming
we have the analogy of this which is
Thursby p' sound let's do it and I'm
gonna use periodical sounds which are
known as oskol eaters and there are
different kinds of oscillators one of
the most common there are signs so what
i'm doing here i'm simple creating
objects of sign and in g bar I can even
image new keywords so only this line I'm
creating greeting the object of sign and
this moment I can run my program we have
thirst beautiful sound
right and keep be aware that since it is
periodical sound I need to stop it
manually as well so I'm running and
stopping it manually that's it how can
we change that how can we change that in
order to create some melody for that we
need just a bit to look into physics ID
because what we are trying to change
that what do we want to modify here
physics saying that sound is vibrations
to travel through some sort of the
material that material is usually just
an ear that means in order to change the
sound we actually wants to change
vibrations how can we do that there are
two ways we can change the frequency
that means how often molecules are
moving in vibrations and that we can get
different pitches so the high frequency
we can get high pitch sound to the low
frequency we can get low pitch sounds
another option we can change the
amplitude how far molecules are moving
in vibrations and that we can get a
different volume so we can get quieter
and louder sounds keep an eye that there
is the range in which we need to modify
in hertz and vegetables because our
human ears have some limitations let's
try to apply these options in deeper how
can we do that there are few ways the
first one we can provide this value
during initialization of this object
that's why now I'm saying that the
frequency here should be for example 600
and we hear different sound if I would
change 600 to 400 how many of you think
that we will get a lower pitch
who thinks that we will get a higher
pitch that's right because we
wrote lower-frequency another way we can
actually move this object to the
wearable for example is here and later
on I can reach the property frequency
and I can modify that as well
and at this point I need to tell you one
interesting thing in jeepers if I'm
using one little variable as s and I am
rewriting my object creation of
different parameters observe what
happens
but if I would change my wallet
available to not one little wearable
[Music]
why why did we here now all sounds
playing at the same time
that's a mystery and I'm not joking here
this is really what documentation says
that the reason for this remains
mysterious but I promised to be revealed
let's be aware of this and we we can
move forward because I promise to you we
can change frequency and amplitude as
well let's do that and it's pretty in
similar way we can do that during
initialization just here we are using
not with default measures which are
decibels for amplitude but we are using
Jabar measures where ricotta would be as
a default sound so let's have something
more than water
and later on something less we hear the
difference and this basics how can we
change amplitude and frequency we can go
to the next level literally because of
cue laters assigned there pretty low
level elements children and there are
more advanced ones which are acting more
as instrument likes there are different
synthesizers and I'm going to use one of
them they are called synth so here now
I'm creating the instrument when I'm
running I do not hear nothing because we
are creating the instrument and later on
we can say what kind of note do I want
to play that lets have same 600
not it's a different sound there are
different kinds of synthesizers which we
can use mama here and there is one
special synthesizer it's called
soundfont soundfont it is sample based
synthesizer that's why I need to say
what kind of sample based you want to
have that let's have something classical
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so this is how we can start to
play some sorta two melodies just to
play will hurt it's pretty tough because
you do not know by heart what kind of
note it is and there is an easier way to
do that because in musical world we can
express no Violetta's for those who are
not familiar this is the correlation
between hurt and letters that means
instead of saying 440 I can say that it
is a note in for cocktail and we can do
that in G bar as well and that is
working with all synthesizers except
sample-based that's why I'm coming back
to the scenes now I'm taking bleep this
time I will add a bit more volume and
let's have 440
and I can change that to a four as I
mentioned we have the same thing let's
talk about another optimization so far
I'm using only one note and I change
that and I need to rerun and run my
program there is a more efficient way to
do that we can provide the list of notes
and to play that for that I need to use
instead of note I need to see play and
now I need to say what kind of notes do
I want to play that lets go for example
three times if Rinat but also I need to
provide another list to say how long
each of note you take let's have the
quota and then something else by default
when I'm gonna run this play I'm gonna
get even the repetition of these notes
[Music]
[Applause]
okay what did we have here I wrote more
notes more times and simpler I ran the
program we heard the difference right
then I moved my list of notes and list
of times to different variables because
I wanted to reduce them for another
instrument for mana now and the last
part I introduced one new element in
Chipper Jones drums are one of the most
popular you always use in terms of how
and for their creation we need to
provide the string of special characters
which are indicates what kind of drums
you want to have we can have open
clothes I have kicks snares and he was
will need to say how long each of them
should take so now you know how we can
add instrument by instrument and how we
can create harmony just I believe you
notice that to write the exact notes
usually taking the most of the time and
for that I prepared another example for
you to show how even more sophisticated
music may look and sound like what do I
have here so far bunch of notes I have
bass notes bass times and then the
concatenation I'm making other notes
melody notes same four times and bass
notes same four times then I have four
different instruments simple if mono
sign I'm making from two different
synthesizers with different parameters
and then I'm simple playing different
melodies with different instruments
keep an eye I'm going to introduce the
last element in G bar which are effects
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all receiver so now you know how
can we use JavaScript to create music to
create that with live coding but I
promise to you that we will look to into
another way of using javascript we will
look into music creation into our web
applications and if we are looking into
the history of audio possibility into
them that is nothing new we have
different ways how we can do that but
today I want to talk about the most
sophisticated way to do that nowadays
which is Web Audio API and why it is so
great it's not that that audio pie
enables us to play replace an audio
track Deb odd API enables us to create
our own sounds to analyze them and
modify as well so basically it enables
us to use browser as synthesizer how
does that work if we have some web
application for that we would need to
create audio context and everything
going to happen there we would store the
audio state there we would create our
source that can be your audio track that
can be oscillating as sine or simple
microphone and then we would need to
connect that to the destination where do
you want to output the sound usually
that is figures if I would like to add
some more modifications or analyzation
that would happen in the middle but this
is the general picture how does that
work and I believe you want to ask me
Laura
how could we create our first beeps
sound simple from browser console this
is the answer we'll create the context
we would create the source you see here
same sign oscillator which we had in
jibber then we simple connect that to
the destination and that's all we would
plate it yes that's a bit more right
inventing cheaper simple same sign but
we do not need any special environment
is cheaper this simple our browser
console and of course of course the Ryan
is our way to do that because we
developers fill up libraries and there
are libraries for that as well one of
them stone
yes if you're reading about pep or API
in mdn documentation you will see tones
yes as a suggestion to use it how many
of you use some gia so far I have some
great news for you I'm going to show you
the source demo how can we do that what
do I have here so far a simple angular
application I just installed zone simple
with NPM install so far I have the
component instrument so you can imagine
we will create our own instrument in the
depth in the HTML I'm just having a
bunch of buttons I'm iterating through
the hard coded notes and when I'm
whenever I click on the note I'm just
playing note I'm passing that exact on
what I was clicked and in TS file in TS
file I have those hard coded tabs and I
have the element from tone library you
see it synth I'm taking that from the
tone and whenever I'm using that in a
function I'm simple triggering the exact
note which is coming from the HTML and
how does that look
you
so we have the instrument which is able
to play any melody any sound we are
playing we do want to play and it's
amazing that only those few lines we
have full range of the instrument but I
think we can make something better we
can go better and I thought that so far
away using only default sound we need to
change that we need to have some unique
taste and I applied some modifications
let's look into them this is unique
incident right katyana instrument as you
noticed probably it's playing cat
samples but still according the right
pitch and I was honestly surprised how
easy that was to make looked on GS
because my imagination I thought that I
would need to change every sample by
myself and then maybe to map at the tone
help but that was way easier than this
let's look into the code not exchange
for the synth part an inch demo as well
nothing changed but now we have the
sampler sampler as well coming from its
own library for sampler initialization I
need to provide what kind of sample
original sample I want to play so you
see it here and as well I need to say
what kind of note original cat was
singing that was tough but it was g2
note and that's all nothing more was
needed to provide I simple just adjusted
the volume because cat was singing very
loudly but nothing more was needed to
provide and that was amazing that Tony
has handled everything for me and as you
seen in the function itself I'm simple
triggering the exact note together with
the synth and this is how we can have
our own instrument now some of you may
think cats sound instrument how useful
it is but don't judge me too soon
because for those few of you I went an
extra mile and I created something
special
something different
[Music]
this is the Gion instrument which plays
dog samples but still according the
right note but not only this I do not
want to overwhelm you with a lot of
details but I want just to show you few
things because there are many different
elements in tone Jia's which you can
handle in different ways and you can
really cover many different cases let's
start that there are different
instruments synthesizers I used before
since now we have something else
policing and we can give different
parameters before we were using always
sine escalator now you see there another
one square going forward important
element part and part may look a bit
complex at the beginning but it does
nothing more than just plays predefined
melodies with predefined instruments you
see for example here I'm using sampler
dock sampler and policing instruments
two instruments and I'm playing melody
chords predefined notes melody chords
I'm taking importing from the constant
files you see it here I predefined every
note I wrote when it should play how
long it should play and what kind of
note and when I am playing this a few
notice the same time this is how we are
getting chords going furthered as well
for part we can describe do we want that
in loop how long that book should take
and and and so on
then we have noise noise as well another
element in
tone library you see I'm taking pink for
example but I'm not playing noise
straightly I'm adding some modifications
as here I'm adding filter which is
making some waving effect and as well
I'm adjusting volume and then I'm on
only playing that back to basics I am
playing some audio tracks you heard we
had some Mario tracks and I'm taking
randomly what kind which one I want to
play at that moment whenever user clicks
and that I'm simple playing it and the
easiest thing we are just can't just
increase tempo for example so there are
different elements in tune J's which you
can use and we can create a different
different music different sounds
according the users actions and usually
when we are thinking about front-end
development our full focus is only on
visual part sometimes we totally forget
that we have all your possibility into
them but please note that sometimes
audio can really enrich our visual part
and in this way we can really create the
next level of user experience in the
depth if you're thinking right now Laura
I've been tricked I've been nice enough
for a front and lecture today don't
worry because of this we're leaving
JavaScript we're leaving JavaScript and
moving forward to totally different
programming language the language which
was specially created for music
programming sonna pi do we have Ruby
developers here you're gonna see some
similarities because sonic PI is based
on Ruby and despite that interestingly
despite that I am a front-end developer
sonic PI was the language which
introduced me music programming
capabilities and originally sonic PI was
created for combination to combine the
lessons at school to combine programming
and music but at the time it was
improved so much that people started to
use that for live coding performances
let's look into Sonia Pinal the thirst
thing Sonic pi is coming together with
the ID so we need to download that
and you already see the thirst beep
sound program in it
let's plate I believe it's pretty easy
to understand what display but what is
60 now is it still frequency yes because
no one change to the physics part so far
but we're using not they're not in Hertz
we're using me these keys here from the
0 to 127 on the other hand we know that
we don't need numbers we can express
that in letters and we can do the same
in Sonic pi we can simple say that it is
C for note and we hear the same thing
going further we can add some options
and we can add for example change the
amplitude the default value here in Sony
pi is 1 so let's have something more and
something this is still playing very
quick ok going further we know that to
play only with one note it's not
efficient and we can as well provide
here the list of notes here we simple
need to say that display patterns time
now and I need to provide the list of
those notes
and another list as you know we need to
say how long each of the know to tick
[Music]
let's go further we even can change the
synthesizers and in sonic way everything
is synthesizer for example piano
synthesizer sine oscillatory synthesizer
even noisy synthesizer but that was
still according the notes that was still
C 4 and C 4 and there are other elements
in 25 for which we even don't need to
provide the notes there are samples
there are different kinds of them
they're simple with your tracks which we
can still modify but no notes are needed
to provide we can simple change that
change that
and we hear different sounds on
everything what I just mentioned we can
add ethics and ethics and Sonic by we
are adding not on some melody or on some
instrument we are adding on everything
what is inside do and block so I'm
adding here slicer and let's have some
another we hear the difference so now we
know how can we change the sounds we can
change the frequency amplitudes basics
we can add different synthesizer to
change them we can add samples and on
top of everything we can add effects but
what about music evolution because so
far our music is finishing very very
fast and we do not have the loops by
default repetition which we had in Chiba
and here in Sonic why we don't have some
hidden functionality we don't have that
by default and that means we need to
implement that explicitly and there are
different kinds of loops in Sonic PI
let's start with some fixed ones when we
know how many times do we want to play
that for example here I will play this
two times but sometimes we don't know
how many times you want to play that
that means we need to use infinite loops
and in music program we really want to
have it because now our result is in the
time and we want to have it as long as
we wish for that let's use some infinite
loop and that will play until I manually
stopped and now we can start to think
about some harmony we have some melody
playing as long as we wish and let's
have some drums playing as well so now
I'm creating another loop I will use
sample drums sample I want to play that
every second so every second I will have
drums and at this moment is there anyone
who do not believe that we will hear
melody and drums playing together
one person to free okay the moment of
truth we do not because this is how a
program works it is executed instruction
by instruction and we are stuck in the
first infinite loop that means we need
to implement concurrency explicitly as
well because we need to play melody and
drums in parallel and how can we do that
for that there is different kind of book
we need to say that this is live look
now different kinds of book and for live
loops creation we need to say the name
the unique name because basically here
we are creating different thread and we
need to have that unique so here I'm
having melody Fred let's have your
chance
[Music]
did you notice did you notice that I
change the instrument simple rerun the
program and without losing the beat we
heard the difference live loops not only
enables us to play something in parallel
it enables us to change music on the
fight to change that during execution so
only now actually we are reaching the
essence in sonic PI and only now we can
go to my last example today of life
coding what do I have here so far I have
a bunch of notes
I'm Sur I'm simple playing some
Lithuanian folk song here you're going
to hear that and then I have the
function which plays four different
chords and I can manipulate this take
time and release time then I have the
live loop for melody live loop for
courts and for drums for recording and I
have some commented code as well you're
going to hear understand why okay let's
start
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you that's all from my
side thanks a lot for coming here
it was my real pleasure to be here thank
you
[Applause]